let's talk about Bubba Smollett oh yeah
oh yeah Bubba sublet bubbles now his
real name is Bubba Wallace okay but I
think he apologized for this right like
he said he was embarrassed yep yeah good
for him well no not necessarily he kind
of did it in the loosest way possible
but I'm gonna pull up his tweet here
because I don't want to read exactly
what so we'll go through the justice
story most of you know this and I got to
tell you man I actually got an email
about this story did you that nailed it
100% got the whole thing right okay
Bubba Wallace relieved by FBI finding no
crime in noose but frustrated by
reaction well he parently changed his
story for those aren't familiar Bubba
Wallace is the only black diaspora I
think they refer to it as Racer in
NASCAR okay and he found a garage pull
cord for the door it's like if you have
a garage you have a pole cord it's tied
in a loop so you can grab it and pull on
it it's easier to do yeah well he found
that and he said it was a noose and then
NASCAR issued this big statement and
then he like drove his car and they all
marched behind them and like sang songs
and whatever and it turns out it was a
pole cord the FBI investigated Tucker
Carlson was very very critical of the
FBI for doing this I did completely
disagree I think I'm glad the FBI did
the FBI found that it was not a noose I
think Tucker's argument was that there
were 15 agents sent there well I'm
people pulling down there was a they did
say a lot of agents were it's truant in
there but I'm glad they did I'm glad
they did these incremental fake hoaxes
no cause so much damage that's true and
it's on par with turning the statue now
should they be doing something about
statues yes but I think as we stated in
a previous segment Trump's strategy is
these Democratic senators are trying to
bait him and they are burning themselves
down you know what if because of all the
chaos and destruction in these blue
states I mean like dude we announced it
a long time ago we're getting out of
Jersey because of how awful Murphy was
it's true this this lunatic of a
governor I'm not kidding marching with
the protesters and then shutting down
businesses and arresting people yeah
that guy lost his mind so we're done you
lose all our business all that tax on
who's gone and I wonder how many other
people are getting are getting out of
Dodge yeah they thought they were gonna
get Trump they thought Trump will come
in and
and help and well the last left nope so
maybe that Trump's Trump strategy is let
them burn their their own State to the
ground they're the ones in charge and
they'll get voted out you know and then
you get a whole bunch of red governors
so Trump at the federal level sends the
FBI to investigate something he can
actually investigate turns out Bubba
Wallace aka Bubba Smollett wasn't real
so he cheated about it right yet the
other tweet well I have it I don't want
to switch right now all that camera
thank you wait I'm pulling up the okay
we are pulling up the tweet from Bubba
Smollett got that you want read it yeah
sure so this this is his response
basically it's been an emotional few
days first off I won't say how relieved
I am or I want to say how relieved I am
that the investigation revealed that
this wasn't what we feared it was I want
to thank my team NASCAR and the FBI for
acting swiftly and treating this as a
real threat I think will gladly take a
little embarrassment over what the
alternatives could have been make no
mistake though some will try this should
not detract from the show of unity we
had on Monday and the progress we've
made as a sport to be more welcoming
environment for all so looking at this
first off he's not saying I was
embarrassed you know he's saying weed so
it's like you should be embarrassed a
little bit yeah it is embarrassing
but at the same time I can I can
emphasize I can see it it's like you
said it earlier people are wound up
tight yeah there is everybody's talking
about race racism this racism races or
everything war like all the stuffs going
on so like I can definitely imagine him
seeing it walking and seeing it it's
like you don't see those things cell
towers right you don't notice them until
someone points them out well do you know
what that is is my favorite cell tower
that's why I'm bringing it up yeah but
it's like the same thing your work and
NASCAR you're not looking at the pull
cord but nowadays what they invited the
environment were in he sees it I I don't
blame you at all Bubba I don't I I don't
I get it it was it sucks and it probably
wasn't him to be and you know what
the feeling that he felt when he saw it
is real and that's people people are
just making fun of him calling him Bubba
Smith some of us molest yeah and I don't
like that because he actually went and
hired some people to do something where
this is completely that's true he saw
this and fell panicked well he felt
something real because it is real in our
history so we have that's not real
actually the fact that they were being
hung 100 years ago that's less than the
leaving I don't know the last time you
know believing news is lying around as
some kind of statements is apparently
like a really new thing Oh God a
historical thing I know no no I I'm not
talking you talking about like Texas
racism it is founded in reality that
we've been through in our in our area so
it's like I get it you know sigh I kind
of feel fail for him for sure the
fairest point is that justice Millette
hired two dudes correct this joke on
Tucker Carlson was amazing I have to
repeat it I came from the guy who said
it but he said America is not a racist
country it turns out and justice
Millette had to hire two foreigners to
do a job Americans would knew when you
and Tucker starts laughing like crazy
like I've never heard that was great and
it's a good point he had two foreigners
to do a job Amer not only that but they
were Nigerian yeah so so Bubba is a
victim of media hysteria and I can I can
I can respect the statement he made what
I can't what I wish you would a little
bit more I have no problem right so the
next door we have that I want to I want
to highlight is the cops did the same
thing right the NYPD who thought their
milkshakes were funky yeah and so it was
their boss who was like shut it down go
to the hospital overreacting panicking
so when I saw this I immediately was
like you know what I jump the gun on
this one I tweeted straight checks
shakin
eyes tweeted Shake Shack straight poison
- cops things are getting insane yeah
and to be fair I thought what I was
saying was like they actually got sick I
don't know how they got sick right but
like they got poisoned from Shake Shack
but they just taste it and they're like
oh this is what I mean to say is my
statement was too definitive and I was
wrong
and so I quita like I'm gonna eat this
one I was totally wrong I jumped the gun
I should have waited
yeah I assumed if it was if the police
had had tweeted it and they and
listed it must have been true a lot of
other journalists made the same mistake
on Covington I should know better right
so that's that's the environment we're
in right now that's it's tense what what
I mean is I have no problem saying I did
a bad job and I'll do better next time
yeah yeah this guy sang will be a little
embarrassed here no no no Bubba just say
it you were wrong
yeah and boy do you feel dumb but it's
okay yeah I would have a lot more
respect if you came out and said yikes
well I look like an idiot I hope you
guys can forgive me for putting you
through this but you got to understand
why I'm wound up a little bit may
something's happen and and and that's
why I can respect two ways you know to
an extent well today it's done and now
now I want to talk about the last part
of it because he says you know it
shouldn't detract from the show of unity
that we had on Monday and it's like look
look man this is where we are now in
life most people are not racist you know
this this is that's it's not just on
Monday it's great everyone came together
and we're like we're really did this
happen well we're gonna make sure we
prove that it didn't happen and it's
like that's the norm people have seen
people seem to believe that racism is
like rampant among everybody and it's
like no that's also a minority a
minority people I don't know any races I
met a few in my life I mean I even cut
them out immediately and I and I blew up
on them and I snapped they know my mind
they know I'm not I'm not about that I
don't talk to them anymore
I think racism is being brought back by
the left yeah I it's get actly it into
free absolutely there are some people so
I was in an uber in Texas and boy was
one of the most uncomfortable rides I've
ever had dude was hardcore racist really
yeah he's a racial slurs mostly
targeting black people and stuff like
this man and you know what was it you
know you know what gave him like what he
was talking about he's talking about the
left and the things they were doing it
opened a door for him to say you notice
all these people coming out with this
black lives matter stuff and they start
going off and it was like the things
that these activists did and I gotta be
honest I I was I was very like he could
tell I was getting angry yeah using
slurs and stuff and the things he was
saying and then he shut it down quick
but this was well after the Dallas
shootings we
the black and India extremists was
killing a bunch of cops you familiar
that yeah I know of it yeah shot a
protester someone was shielding her kids
and so this guy's going off about black
lives matter and stuff and he's just
going hard at it and I'm like thinking
to myself you know what man this guy's a
racist but now he thinks because of what
they've done I can say whatever I want
because people are gonna agree because
they don't like it probably that's
stereotyping it's saying that all I saw
one person of this specific race do
something bad everybody of that race is
well that's not that same person I think
that is a problem no I think this guy
was overtly racist for other reasons
probably sure and I think what he was
thinking that does equate that that is
what happened though he is doing that
he's I know that this guy did it so they
all are like that I'm gonna just put
another racket no no no not him maybe
not consciously what I'm saying is that
because of these negative stories in the
press it gave him an opportunity to say
hey you hate those guys killed those
cops right no Mikey aniele's yeah and
then he goes off so once he gets you to
agree with him all these things they're
doing is bad right
they're shooting people they're out
throwing bricks and fireworks and stuff
and you're like if it's all awful and
then he tries pushing to see how far I
can take you what I'm saying is racists
are being emboldened by the extremist
actions of the left in the name of
racial justice and they know that
regular people are getting scared of the
violence and it's giving an opening to
racist to be like ooh now's my chance
yeah well I mean I'm not saying they
don't agree they don't exist you know
but I it's not the norm anymore it's
certainly not and a lot of these people
that they're a lot older relics of a
bygone era like Biden yeah that's the
first thing that pops in my head dude
some really old old racist person yep
yeah you're right LRD troubles yeah man
I am so happy I don't have allergies all
right I feel bad for people to do yeah
well c'est la vie I don't think it's
allergies I think I just sneezed
sometimes people sneeze well yeah to go
to go to the that the police thing too
in LA a guy claimed he had a tampon in
his Frappuccino or whatever okay clearly
was not a tampon yet we were talking
about this yesterday when it happened
because I I came up with this they queue
across the Serena's
holy cow this is crazy you know this
biohazard if it really is like a gross
used tampon whoa yeah it's disgusting
right and then a few minutes later Tim's
like no this is this is not this is fake
news or whatever and I was like good
that's I was like I'm not falling for
this again but I was like the firt my
first response was that makes me feel so
much better about people and that's kind
of what I see happening with Bubba
because he's like I see a positive side
to this like this isn't the way people
really are look I'm embarrassed but I'm
really glad this is the case you know
people gotta stop making fun of them
it's like it it's an embarrassment
people are allowed to make mistakes
people are allowed to make mistakes you
know I mean if he's if he's gonna lean
into it and double down and after
knowing he did now that that's a little
bit different of a story right you know
that's that's getting into the Smollett
side of things yep it's like well make
it remind Bubba but he realized he was
gonna lose so he was like a video view
of him and on Don Lemon he was like it
was a noose and he's like it was a pole
cord it was a straight news mm-hmm I saw
a picture of it it was tiny someone sent
me screenshots yeah but like so a bunch
of stories are going viral showing lines
pointing things out in the garage right
someone sent me this like very early on
and I saw it now I was like I don't know
enough about it so it's like interesting
and then sure enough when the story
comes out you know they use similar
images and I was like there it is
somebody sent me the tip first you know
but you know what am I gonna do so it
turns out it was a yeah and he walked
into that one
yep and I guess he didn't even see it
himself is that true you think someone
else noticed a someone else pointed out
to him like hey you see that noose there
that's for you like who's that person
that's what I want to know who said that
to him
who put that idea someone who is also
who is naive and who was wound up tight
yeah freaking out the media is telling
you the world is ending the Nazis are
here yeah
was it voxcom said four million people
think think like neo-nazis in this
country isn't like that Wow
it's like that's insane men like numbers
up I don't
3000 clan members in the country nine
people people show 9,000
yep nine nine nine yeah this was like no
people will always be like Tim you're so
boys - why won't you talk about the far
right and I'm like what about him what
about the three thousand clan members
who don't show up for their own meetings
don't do anything what what what about
Darrell Davis was effectively d
radicalized tons of them who couldn't
effectively D atony radicalized the edge
of uh people right what about the end of
a people show up to every single major
political rally and Trump rally and
attack people not only did they they
like did he not able to radicalize or
not rowdy radicalize them they called
him a white supremacist yep so it's like
how does that make any sense so you have
to understand what white supremacy means
to them right it means liberal democracy
right it does being a citizen an
upstanding citizen of America it's a
report that's yes but also go ahead it's
not a reference to white supremacy to
them are the institutions of Western
countries period right okay so a court
of law is white supremacy a library is
white supremacy I'm not exaggerating
everything they view it as white
Europeans invented the concept of time
time is white supremacists crazy
I'm not kidding remember that woman I
said time is white supremacy yes yep
time was white she literally a professor
right I think so yeah and she was like
time as white supremacist they think
anything white people have done is part
of the system of white supremacy and so
what dumb leftists and Democrat Democrat
voters don't realize there's a very
clever tactic on the part of the far
left yeah so you get your average
Democrat voter and they'll say do you
want to march against white supremacy
and they'll go oh of course
as they're thinking the Klan and
neo-nazis right what they're really
protesting is roads router faucets
everything I'm not exactly yeah stores
faith that's why that one woman on
Twitter said on a Twitter bio destroy
civilization they really do want to live
in you know tribes
roaming the fields it's not an
exaggeration well I mean it's it's their
animal
instincts probably taken over instead of
their like higher
yeah higher higher mind that we try to
hold ourselves above you know animals
but we're all animals they're developing
there's some people yeah yeah they want
to go back to the to the living in trees
and I don't think they do I I think they
just haven't thought through what's
gonna happen I think they think they're
gonna keep all the nice fun capitalist
stuff in the front they think good if we
have communism then Febby Jews are free
that's true and then everyone gets a
Frappuccino they don't even the concept
of like finite materials and production
and labour yes up I thought I saw a
Trump hating post today from someone
that I know and it was basically about
him taking back some environmental stuff
in America and and there was I was
reading the comments and I know some of
these people in there and I'm like you
realized that all of you have phones and
we get all those phones from other
countries that have zero environmental
control they don't care what happens
over there and you guys are all compared
complaining about Trump trying to be I
mean you realize he's trying to bring
the factories here where we will
regulate them I mean he's he's there's a
fine line but that's the reason why he's
doing this and they were all like wow we
didn't think about that
I'm like yeah well you know where your
iPhone came from right on the other side
of the planet where you don't think
about but here you're complaining about
something on your computer mind you now
that was made over there with no
environment and then you get all it's
like come on but that the cult is very
good
who's that comic book guy who makes the
really like fit like five-year-old level
intelligence comics where he's like you
have an iPhone but complain about
society I'm so smart you know that comic
they always send you so they have they
have these straw man rebuttals because
they're in a cult right they can't
actually formulate their own cohesive
response right the comic is it's a
peasant carrying sticks and he says we
should improve society somewhat and then
a guy pops out of a well gonna like this
is his fingers and he goes yet you live
in society haha and he thinks the point
against when people say to the fallout
activists you want to have all these
regulations yet you have an iPhone
because there's no real risk
to it this guy makes up a fake straw man
response of you want to improve society
yet yet you live in it and the point
he's making is just because you have an
iPhone doesn't mean that you have no
right to demand things are better and
it's like that's technically the truth
but I thought the point we're making
right the point we're making is that
you're demanding environmental
regulations to stop the pacific plastic
gyre and then giving money of the people
who are making the plastic gyre if you
want to stop the slave labor and you
want to improve human rights give your
money to people who enforce human rights
the ones in America boom and that is so
annoying about that comic yeah where
it's like I'll fix the comic for you
it's a guy who's not in the society
laughing about how awful the society is
and then the other guy laughing saying
but you live in it and he doesn't listen
yeah I know it makes me mad because it's
like it's like watching it's like a
bunch of clowns yeah these people are
clowns yeah they're and it's like when
you walk up to them and they're like you
know they're eating glass and then
they're going or what kind of stomachs
aren't they fall over and you go yo yo
stop beating glass and then they all
start going their noses and dancing
around like this don't have them or
doing that the other half are like don't
tell us what to do other loans have them
are eating glass and you're like stop
eating glass it's just you're dying well
I don't know if you knew this about
but clowns are now evil and are in half
of all yes all right
yeah yeah because there's emergence
there's a meme about cars they're the
clown world mean and the far-left
argues that people who post the emoji of
a clown in the world are neo-nazis okay
because some neo-nazis post the clown in
the world
but it's a reference to this idea that
everything's gone so insane certainly we
must be in a sitcom written by clowns
yep but other people have pointed out
there's this who wrote the the story of
the clown and the theater and the fire
yeah I'm talking about I think so you
look it up yeah yeah there's a famous
story it's like a poem or something or a
short story where a clown guard
kierkegaard fire a fire breaks out
backstage and the clown runs out that's
warning the audience the fire the fire
and they'll start laughing and then he
says no no no there's a serious fire
it's gonna kill you all and they all
laugh and laugh and then it burns down
they all die and his little quote it's
really short I ain't really so sure it
was it says a fire broke out backstage
in a theater the clown came out to warn
the public they thought it was a joke oh
my gosh go away you stupid pop-up thing
and applauded he repeated it the acclaim
was even greater I think that's just how
the world will come to an end to general
applause from wits who believed it's a
joke so and you know what hold on I just
want to get this out we a lot of people
are looking all these people that are
ripping down statues and they're like
this is a joke these are jokers just
like what you were saying the other day
it's like these this is gonna pass over
these jokers that's what someone told me
today ah it'll stop they'll go get bored
no they won't
yep escalating non-stop yeah but it's
the it's the clowns that are doing
insane things for insane reasons and if
you try and talk to them they just smile
and go and they're like you're like
you're not responding to me you're not
answering my question when they post
that comic of the guy going yet you live
in society it's like you realize you
didn't answer what my point was right
but you are literally giving money to
the Chinese establishment which has
slave labor committing suicide and mass
for cheap products they jack up the
price on which contributes to plastic
pollution around the planet and don't
burn in my phone
okay buy american-made phones boom yet
you live in society well I don't you
have to buy an iPhone Brown to live
somewhere yeah yeah it's it's but it's
like yeah so someone once told me I'm
more effective with this computer and I
said you can buy a computer from
somewhere else
like you there's no obligation on a
MacBook right seriously but you live in
430 oh shut up that's a strum and excuse
so you can buy your luxury goods Duke
your Starbucks and then pretend like
you're allowed to do it right
yeah and that's that's what it's part of
the saying right the snowflake doesn't
blame itself for the Avalanche excellent
saying they say so I'm allowed to have
an iPhone it's other people who aren't
yeah yeah yet you live with these people
are so dumb and they get these these
people who craft these these these
stupid messages to defend their
ignorance mmm-hmm and they post it all
the time it's really it's really funny
like so I tweeted the other day a oc1
and then I said something like perhaps
people are not happy you know they don't
want things to go back to where they
were someone responded with like you
kept claiming she was gonna lose and I
said yes months and months ago when
stories were coming out suggesting she
was gonna lose it's really that simple
when a story comes out saying Wall
Street was heavily funding Michelle
Crusoe Cobra I was like whoa is a bad
sign for a OC she could really lose in
this case if her opponents raising
ridiculous tons of you know ridic a
really good ridiculous sums I was
dabbling establishment cash then we have
the economists data saying that
progressives keep losing Vox anchor
guesses keep losing so yes in those
contexts and then in the past month I
said AO C's gonna win she's probably
gonna win I don't think I'm CeCe's gonna
gonna win but they what they do is they
take really really old things that are
totally out of context and and they
craft these memes and then they can all
use them as their one-off without paying
attention or actually know what they're
talking about you know and that's how
they defend their insanity well I read
it online so it must be true yeah I saw
her see look my friend my my credited
friend sent me this so I believe it yep
clowns I noticed a bunch of people
posted clown emojis and the okay hand
sign all I can picture is do the Jeff of
you doing could you imagine trying to
talk to somebody and you're like I think
we have a serious problem with the
structure of our tax system now a lot of
people are concerned about health care
but first I think we need a real
reallocate taxes away from foreign
intervention Airi war and regime change
so we could we could reallocate those
funds and they look at you and go you're
like are you supporting her I don't
speak and you're like what what's
happening I thought we having a
conversation and then they start
throwing pies at you and it's like how
am I supposed to have a conversation
right now like yeah and and and then
they turn around and there's a voting
booth and they and they're dancing like
this and they grab the lever and slowly
turn their head
no one else saw that it was directly
over me they're dancing they're dancing
and my head spins all the way around
very slowly and stares at you as they
pull the lever for some lunatic yeah and
and and then and you're like who are you
voting for and you look and you can see
the print out and on the receipt is a
clown face and you're like no you don't
know you don't go yes I'm gonna go with
that dreaming I woke up then you walk
outside and there's these wake up please
wake up please wake up now the funny
thing about all this is that I think
many Trump supporters are just in a
luckier position in that they're not on
the side of the authoritarian wingnuts
who are banning speech you can complain
about Trump and call him all the worst
names in the book Trump is doing very
little unfortunately he's not banning
speech he's actually not doing a whole
lot to protect speech online so it's
like he's doing not a lot you there are
the Republicans it's the it's the left
that is banning things burning things
tearing down statues making stuff happen
that's true there we're not good stuff
but but the point is these these people
think they're not the clown's
they're all dressed like clowns and I
gotta be honest a lot of them literally
just like yea shaved heads pink spiky
hair and weird things on their face
that's a good point and they're
everywhere and they make no logical
sense it's just like what I was saying
before it's like when you're making
cookies and you cut out the cookies and
they got that weird leftover dough you
can't really cook or do anything with
you it's like these people are only
fragments of of a functioning member of
society because there's nothing for them
to do anymore because we've progressed
too much a technology so now they're
like I don't know what I'm talking about
I don't know to do and they can only do
half-assed things they can't do one
functioning job they just are a bunch of
little tiny things here and there
odd jobs and that's the gig economy to
be honest people who do menial tasks
delivering package and I don't mean an
offensive to the people actually do
these jobs because you know to their
credit they're literally doing jobs I
mean that we have a whole generation of
people who have no specialty tasks
anymore yeah so they're aimless and
they're and they're looking for that
hard purpose and they find it in Dogma
yeah now they've got a whole persona
yeah now they've fulfilled themselves
they're no longer just that weber driver
they're the activists for social justice
revolutionary fighting in the
underground fight ya laddies estas Viva
and they run out and they go and smash
windows and they think they've changed
the world thanks for checking out this
clip from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do
the show live Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. if you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or check us out on
iTunes and Spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you